the hunt begins we're talking about apex
legends more specifically bloodhound and
what it takes to be the best tracker you
can be Eric what's the quick rundown on
this legend bloodhound is the
technological tracker the only recon
legend currently in the game the legend
is there to provide a bunch of
information to your team give you
scouting information and give you
tactical advantages speaking of tactical
advantages the first ability that
bloodhound has is the eye of the
all-father which briefly reveals enemies
traps and clues throughout the
structures ahead of you what's important
there is ahead of you is key right
because you and I both started playing
very early on then figured that the
bubble that comes out appears to be 360
but it's not right the bubble is more to
warn enemies I think just to give them a
fair advantage but it has to be in front
of you doesn't matter if it's upstairs
Downstairs as long as you have them in
front of you or know that there's
somewhere in front of you you hit that
ability what's gonna tell you where they
are however that doesn't mean that
that's where they're gonna be so you
kind of have to be predictive you have
to make sure that you're not too honed
in on the silhouette you know they're
they're gonna start moving don't shoot
the silhouette I've done that a couple
of times like oh they're right there
oh crap they've actually moved us
slightly to the left or right so just be
aware of that right don't don't
necessarily chase the hologram that's
left try to predict where they're
running just think ahead for sure
yeah and as we mentioned it will give
away your position so be cautious with
it next on the list is the passive
ability tracker which allows bloodhound
to see tracks left behind your foes from
up to 60 seconds or less well your
thoughts on this ability it is awesome
but also it's a lot of information to
take in are then the biggest thing you
should take away from it is it kind of
goes from dark red to kind of like pink
or white and so you know if it's dark
red oh crap they've been here they're
really close I've ever watch out you
know if it's older information it starts
to fade to white a little bit pink and
you don't have to be as concerned but it
does give you a lot of information it
kind of gives you if an enemy's use the
zip line if they've mantled something
and knowing the weapon is actually
pretty important because okay it's a
peacekeeper
maybe we fight mid to long range because
this person wants to be up close and in
the fray and the other part too is like
if you find something good like a good
piece of info as you mentioned hover
over that and ping in you can relay all
this information to your team and if you
don't have a mic you should totally be
using that system last but not least the
ultimate ability beasts of the hunt
it's probably the best part about
bloodhound Erik what you say about it I
think it's awesome it gives you a speed
up so you are moving you are trucking
you can use that movement speed in
various ways you know to flank a team to
outrun a circle maybe you just engaged
in the team and you're like I gotta get
out of here maybe already popped all you
can tell Italy get out of there right
wouldn't used to the hunt you can use it
just to book it across the map it can't
be jarring at first because it kind of
goes black and white right but maybe
that helps you see the enemies even
easier and it's just awesome it pairs
well as you mentioned earlier with
against smoke or with smoke from
Bangalore or even with the caustic or
against a caustic because you're not
afraid of the lack of bigan you can now
see through that and basically have map
hacks in a way you know I hear a great
please smoke your teammate and revive
them because now I'm gonna get both of
you because I can see exactly where
you're at
the other part about beats of the hunt
just like the tactical is that one and
it needs to hear you engage it and
secondly people will know you have it
engaged if they're looking at you
because your eyes glow red if you are
near the bloodhound and it's still
active you can actually hear it you can
hear that bloodhound has it triggered
and it's actually pretty terrifying well
cool that was the ultimate ability any
other final tips Eric you have with
bloodhound yeah we're talking about the
crows um you'll see them from time to
time I'm not exactly sure what they
indicate you know we thought maybe
enemies at one point but then I saw them
and then there weren't any enemies that
close so maybe just to tell you there's
information that that's what I'm
thinking and a lot of people on reddit
are kind of thinking the same it's not
really so defined I think it's the crows
are essentially a reminder or the game
kind of nudging into saying like hey
there's a bunch of information near you
from an enemy team that was here or a
firefight that happened why do you look
around and see if you can find anything
of useful for you and then the last
thing was something that you said
happened to you was that Mirage as he
has the hologram and the cloak when he
when he has is Oulton gauged you could
see his footsteps right yeah it was
interestingly in a final circle I've
never seen this interaction before you
know he uses his ultimate ability to try
to either blankets or kind of you know
just get away right and then all of a
sudden I'm like I see him because of the
silhouette because you can still see it
but I see a trail of footsteps as he's
running towards me and I'm like oh I've
never seen that before that's cool I
make sense right because bloodhound
is a tracker yeah and that's gonna do it
for this bloodhound guide for more
guides on apex legends stay tuned to
game spot